So I think this leaves us in a position
where we can actually state the TD(1)
update rule.
So it looks a little hairy, but we're
going to be able to go through it and
see that it does something very
sensible, or at least somewhat sensible.
So this is the structure of the rule,
of TD(1).
So for each time we start a new episode,
we're going to initialize this thing
called the eligibility,
e(s) for all the states, to 0.
So we just start them off as
ineligible at the start of the episode.
And we start off our estimate for
the value function for this episode,
to be initialized to whatever it was
at the end of the previous episode.
>> That makes sense.
>> So then, each time we take a step
within the episode, a step from some
St-1 to some state St, getting reward
rt, what we're going to do is first,
update the eligibility of
the state that we just left.
Then go through all the states, compute
this one quantity which is the same for
all states,
this is the temporal difference.
This is the sum of the reward
plus the discounted
value of the state that we just got to,
minus the state that we just left.
And we're going to use the values that
we had from the previous iteration,
previous episode.
That's going to be our
temporal difference.
And we're going to apply that
temporal difference to all states,
proportional to the eligibility
of those states,
and of course the learning rate,
because we don't want to move too much.
And we're just going to
update them by that.
We're going to increase them by
this temporal difference times
the eligibility.
Then we decrease, or decay,
the eligibility for those states.
And then we're back up to the next step.
>> Okay it's got all
the right letters so
I think I can imagine that
this will do something.
So, the for all S part, does that
have to be done in specific order?
>> No, because the S's are all
being done in parallel here.
So the value at state S is going to be
updated based on this quantity, which is
the same for everybody, doesn't depend
on which S we're currently updating, and
this quantity which is specific
to the S that we're looking at.
So it's all kind of happening
in parallel without any
dependencies between them.
>> Yeah, okay, I see.
So because there's an order to the
states and the way we're going to visit
them, you basically get to see that
value kind of applied everywhere.
Okay, okay, I think I understand.
>> Okay, all right,
so let's kind of step this
through in a tiny little example.
And then see the magic of it,
see that it actually produces the same
outcome that we would have gotten with
the update rule that had
talked about previously.
>> Okay.